stockfish 12 has won the tcec
super computer tournament now this is a
watershed moment in computer chess
it definitively shows that this new
approach that stockfish 12 uses
that includes brute force computing
looking at millions of positions per
second
and neural networks that deep positional
understanding that leela has
is the strongest approach available
today
it will probably require another
watershed moment
in artificial intelligence to build a
stronger type of chess
engine without further ado let's look at
one of my favorite victories from
stockfish in this event
an amazing sicilian game as i've already
indicated here the
opening is a sicilian we get e4 and c5
now the opening moves are dictated by
the tcec
so we're going to zip through here to
move six that's when we get the
interesting move
6g4 in this position this is the fifth
most popular move
in this position to a human this would
look much more natural if the knight
were already on f6
then this would basically be like a
carries attack one of the strongest
openings available to white in the
sicilian
depending on how black plays but in this
case the move looks a little bit
premature to a human at least
but it turns out to be very strong it's
important in looking at these
opening moves to understand the tcec
the tcec picks the opening moves to
ensure
interest and diversity in the positions
and then both engines have to play the
position once with white
and with black so in this case stockfish
has white
but in the game before this it had black
and had drawn a long
and difficult game so here after the
move g4
both engines continued in the same way
we get h6
h4 pawn to a6 and now a move that i
would not have considered
knight takes c6 now possibly partially
due to the influence of engines we're
seeing more of this kind of move
in sicilians but at least instinctively
to me
and my classical chess education it
seems very odd to trade an active knight
for a more passive one
and to reinforce the center for your
opponent when you do it
and then to allow them a half open b
file that also looks pretty useful
as well however it turns out that this
is really kind of good for white because
the pieces jump to active squares
and black's pieces are struggling in
some ways and particularly it becomes
difficult
to develop the king side over here for
reasons that will break down
in a moment in any case after the
recapture here on c6 the move queen d3
is played
by stockfish now in its game against
leela when it had the black pieces
lila had continued with queen f3 and
then there was the move d5
so this game is going to develop on
entirely different lines
after the move queen d3 i think a very
human move would be rook to b8
but then good is b3 and you have the
idea of bishop a3
and castle's queen side in some lines
now
i don't know about you but i've never
seen a sicilian where you play bishop a3
but the idea of that orphion kettling
the bishop turns out to be
really really strong and effective in
this particular opening
it's not like it's winning but it's
certainly a worthwhile idea
for white in any case in this game the
move knight to f6 is played and of
course
that invites the advance of the g pawn
so we do get g5
pawn takes g5 and bishop takes g5
now this structure over here isn't one
that i see too often in a sicilian
the position here with you kind of
having opened up the half open h-file
for this rook over here you having a pin
here
but it turns out to be very strong and
we'll see some of the tactics that
stockfish gets as a result
so after the recapture with bishop takes
g5 we see queen b6 attacking b2
and castles now you would have to be a
very greedy player
i think greedier than yasser sarawan to
consider
queen takes f2 in this position you're
underdeveloped and you should not be
capturing pawns like this
of course there is a punishment and it
is swift it is the move pawn to e5
you can't capture because there is mate
and
although you can avoid mate with for
example knight d5 there is now knight to
e4
attacking the queen winning a pawn back
on d6 and
obviously maintaining a huge huge lead
in development
so after castles we instead see the move
pawn to a5 over here on the queen side
now queen to f3 bishop to d7
bishop to c4 rook b8 of course
we're not going to drop b2 the computer
will never drop b2 bishop to b3
and now in this position i think it's
important to note that bishop e7
kind of seems like the most natural move
here but
it turns out that after h5 the idea of
h6
undermining the knight on f6 is really
strong and it's hard to hold this
position for black
well impossible to hold this position
for black
as a result it's basically impossible to
develop the king
side and that's a big part of stockfish
12's advantage in this position
so the move c5 is played black is
banking
fully on counter play on the queen side
there's possibly the idea of pawn to a4
and a more serious threat seems to be
the move pawn to c4
when you don't want to capture because
you'll drop b2 so you might win the
bishop here on b3
but it turns out that there is a way for
stockfish to allow this
pawn to h5 the threats on the king side
are more serious than the loss of the
bishop on b3
if you play pawn to c4 here very deep
analysis
shows that h6 is winning for white it
turns out that you can give up the
bishop on b3 and after the recapture
your king is totally safe and the
threats
over here on the king side are going to
net you a piece back
at least or a winning attack now the
idea of just capturing hero on g7 and
then capturing on f6 is of course
immediate and very dangerous so the
knight kind of needs to move from f6
but if you try knight h7 there is then
bishop to e3 pulling back the attacked
bishop and attacking the queen in turn
queen to b7 h takes g7 bishop takes g7
and now queen g3 it certainly doesn't
seem like white should have so much
but in this position after this bishop
is either exchanged or removed from this
diagonal in some other way by being
chased off
there's going to be too much pressure on
the h file and the queen can come into
g7
it turns out that this will win material
back thanks to the tactical problems
due to this pin and that's going to be
enough for a winning advantage for
example bishop f6
and the excellent move bishop to d4
trying to exchange off that bishop
if you try to keep it with e5 there's
knight d5 and white's advantage
is decisive you can also consider knight
to g8 but then again
pawn takes g7 bishop takes g7 and you're
going to invade on the h file
after rook h1 and for example bishop e5
rook h7 this pawn is too soft and again
white's advantage is decisive very very
nice
very deep stuff so after pawn to h5
what we actually see is a4 now it's
possible to play knight takes a4 because
if the bishop captures you can capture
back with check so there's no time to
capture here on b2
and after knight takes a4 we get queen
to a5 trying to get
some counter play over here on the queen
side
so queen to a5 bishop takes f6
and pawn takes f6 the knight falls back
to c3
queen back to b6 queen to d3
stopping c4 here king up to e7
a3 bishop h6 check king to b1
and rook hc8 threatening again pawn to
c4
with devastation now queen c4
this move obviously stops c4 but it
looks
very very superficial in fact if you
showed me this position without having
seen the game and the computer analysis
i would probably think that black is not
doing so badly here
after all this bishop is unopposed on
the dark squares it looks like the king
is safe behind this wall of pawns
and how are you going to kind of advance
the h pawn which should kind of be your
trump in this position
but deep analysis shows that white does
have dangerous threats here there are
ideas like pawn to e5
and other ways of breaking through and
black can really do nothing in the
position
so rook c6 is played now look over to e1
it certainly looks like the build up is
very dangerous here
but how do you break through rook c7
rook to d3 and the losing move is the
next move
but it may already be impossible to save
the position at least it's very
difficult for black
for example a natural move like rook c
to c8 here allows
e5 with a very very strong maybe
decisive attack
capturing with this pawn opens up the
possibility of invasion on this diagonal
which is dangerous
and capturing with the d-pawn instead
opens the d-file which is also very
dangerous
the king is not feeling safe on e7 and
this idea of pawn to e5
is a problem and there are other ideas
that also increase the pressure and
black is tied down without counter play
so in the game the move bishop f4 is
played
and i think having seen the way the game
develops that we can say
definitively that this is the losing
move but it takes one of the deepest
combinations that i've ever seen
to show that it is the move knight
to d5 check this
is an amazing move it looks simple
but it's very deep and white will have
to invest more material to break through
now of course knight d5 is forking all
the things
everything in the black camp basically
is forked so you must capture the knight
pawn takes pawn takes and this has
opened up an attack
on this bishop here on f4 and of course
there is the check now
on the king on e7 so the only way to
keep the material is bishop e5
now at this point you might be thinking
that wasn't so deep
i just play f4 pin it and win it i get
my bishop back
and come on that's easy of course the
computer saw that i just can't believe
it was allowed
but in this position there is bishop b5
with a counter skewer and it is black
who wins
so what is the solution it turns out to
be the very patient move
queen to h4 avoiding the skewer here and
threatening rook takes e5
pawn takes and then d6 check for example
if c4 with a fork here then rook takes
e5
is more important white's threats get
there first
pawn takes d6 check and white is winning
but there are alternatives right so
after queen h4 what if you move the king
well basically white's ideas white's
ideas still include rook takes e5
or pawn to f4 so if you try for example
king f8
then f4 is just too strong if you try
bishop d4 here you could actually go for
rook takes
pawn takes you're down a rook but with
queen takes here intending something
like
pawn to h6 and multiple other moves then
you're just winning the game
the massive pieces over here on the
queen side is
irrelevant certainly the king is what
matters in this case
so it makes sense that king d8 was
played in the game
the king is trying to run over to this
side of the board where it hopes to be
safe but now there's another amazing
move
rook takes e5 anyway
after rook takes e5 white is going to be
down a
full rook without a good hope of
recouping most of the material right
away
pawn takes e5 and you might be expecting
d6 but this is actually a mistake
that encourages the rook to go to a
better square stronger as played in the
game
is rook to f3 and tending rook to f6
and of course the h pawn is also a
problem as indicated after king c8
and then h6 in this position and this is
the game
now this is a good moment to pause and
assess a little bit white is down a rook
and as
the king is running over here there is
certainly no hope of checkmating this
king anymore
white only has two pawns for the rook
how can this be good
well it turns out that white only has
two pawns for the rook now
but a lot of black's pawns are falling
very very quickly
so white will soon have not just two but
three and then
four and then five pawns for the rook
and there's not a lot black can do about
it
also black's pieces are not really able
to do anything effective in terms of
counter play
and the h pawn is pretty strong now
black can kind of deal with the h
pawn but doing so will tie down pieces
so all of this mounts up to a winning
position for white
if you for example play c4 here which is
the only
attempt for counter play here there is
h7 threatening to promote with check
king to b7 and promoting here is too
early because of
the simple capture and then the capture
of this bishop
uh although i don't think you can
capture the bishop right away
but the strongest move here is just
bishop takes c4
threatening rook to b3 threatening
promotion and because the king is on b7
there is no mate on b2 so
after pawn to h6 and then king to b7
we now see bishop c4 bishop a4 rook
takes f6
three pawns for the rook queen a5 the
excellent queen e4 which threatens this
and controls e1
no check from the queen and bishop b5
d6 check bishop c6 queen takes e5
four pawns for the rook rook over to e8
queen f5 rook d7 rook takes f7 and
five pawns for the rook so we're back to
material equality
and clearly winning here queen d8 rook
g7
king b6 b4 as a human you probably would
not want to open up your own king in
this position you would want to play
more conservatively
but the engine of course is calculating
deeply it's not concerned about illusory
threats to the kink it can see if
there's actually any substance to those
threats
pawn takes pawn takes rook takes g7
queen to c5
check king b7 pawn takes g7 rookie one
check
king up to b2 queen f6 and it looks like
white has gone wrong
the g7 pawn presumably the best pawn on
the board
is falling however again these are
computer engines they calculate
so deeply it is one of the strengths of
stockfish new is that it also calculates
deeply in addition to having deep
positional evaluations
so it's calculated that after pawn c3
the loss of the g7 pawn is okay
because b5 is coming there's no good
place for the bishop to move it goes to
e4
and it's very impressive here that
exchanging this bishop off is still
enough to win
bishop d5 check i think that exclamation
point move
bishop takes queen takes d5 check and
here after king a7 the engine
surrendered first off if you go king c8
which seems natural because you want to
stay
close to the possibly promoting pawn
there's of course
check and then you have a skewer or this
square and you pick up the queen here on
g7
but why did black resign after king a7
well it turns out that d7 is just over
right and you're going to make a queen
and okay there's like a check
but it doesn't lead anywhere this is
just winning for white
but a human a human could definitely
still mess this up
a very human mistake here would be the
move b6
check after the king has gone to a7 in
the final position
now why would you include b6 check the
point
would be that after the king captures or
falls back
when you push d7 your next move will be
promoting
with check that seems useful that seems
like a good
clean calculation that makes things a
little bit easier for you
kind of giving you an extra tempo the b
pawn doesn't matter if you're making a
new queen
why not give it up to make sure that you
promote with check
well the problem with this b6 check move
is that it's too clever for its own good
you have king b8 by black here not
capturing the pawn
and it turns out that the position is a
draw because of
d7 and now rook b1 check
exclamation point king takes b1 queen g1
or queen gives any other check and then
the queen is going to sacrifice herself
there's no way out of the checks
unless you ultimately capture the queen
at some point and when you do
it is stalemate with the king on b8 but
of course
a computer's not falling for that in the
past it might have happened
but not today and after king a7
resignation is of course
justified i hope that you've enjoyed
this game congratulations to stockfish
12
on winning the tcec congratulations to
its developers on their great
achievements in computer chess
if you want to see more incredible games
from stockfish or from lila
then click on the playlist that is
popping up on your screen right as i
finish here